day was a towering day for justice
as we saw gillian maxwell was sentenced
to 20 years in prison for the crimes she
committed against these survivors and so
many others
today showed us
that individuals can be held accountable
irrespective of power and privilege
and today showed us
that the chorus of voices of these
survivors
prevailed and showed accountability
it's really a victorious day for justice
and on behalf of all the survivors we've
represented we want to thank the
prosecutors for their fierce and
relentless pursuit of justice here we
want to thank the judge for being just
and true and thoughtful
and we want to thank all of you for
never stopping and continuing to pursue
this story and make sure that their
voices were heard so now annie's going
to make a few statements how did the
survivors feel about maxwell's apology
i think they can probably speak to that
but um personally for me that was not an
apology she once again did not
acknowledge her crimes did not take
responsibility for them in any way so
that was really disappointing
may this sentence demonstrate that it is
never too late for the truth to come out
and never too late for there to be
accountability
if you're someone who's experienced
sexual abuse or exploitation
and did not feel safe to report those
crimes
or were not believed when you did or
were told that the perpetrators would
not be held accountable this is for you
there's still a lot of work to be done
on this issue
but in this fight we need to celebrate
the victories and today this is a big
victory
the truths about these crimes about
child sexual abuse and exploitation
are deeply uncomfortable
they happen more frequently than we want
to acknowledge
and often perpetrators as we saw in this
case are not strangers and vans they're
the people that live in our communities
and they're people often in positions of
power
maxwell and epstein were predators who
were able to use that power and
privilege to harm countless individuals
and for far too long the institutions
that should be protecting the public
were instead protecting them
and i still hope that we find out more
about how that was allowed to occur
we know that historically though that
this has happened in many organizations
and many institutions that predators are
protected
um
in you know in churches in political
groups in the foster care system and so
i just hope that this sentence can be
another sign that voices are coming
together and saying no more
if you commit these crimes you will be
punished if you facilitate these crimes
you will be punished if you are a
bystander that looks the other way you
will not be allowed to continue to hold
a position of power
it's easy to focus on the darkness in
the case like this
but i also think it's important to
highlight all the people that have
worked so hard to bring the truth to
light
and i want to start by expressing my
gratitude and appreciation for my sister
maria farmer
who reported these crimes
over decades ago and has so bravely
continued to try and bring attention and
fight for justice in this case
for all for the other women who support
who spoke in the courtroom
i am so grateful
for the other survivor sisters that i
have met on this journey who have worked
so hard to make this happen i am
incredibly grateful this would not have
happened without so many voices coming
together
i am so incredibly grateful for my team
of attorneys most especially sigrid
mcauley who has gone above and beyond at
every step of the way to support us and
encourage us that this could happen
uh for brad edwards and his team
for
the for the media who were you know
really i think continued to tell the
story and try and bring attention to
this case
to uh the agents who worked so hard and
dedicated themselves these last few
years to the maxwell case
and to the fierce team of prosecutors
who took a chance to bring this to trial
and to show that she could be held
accountable for this heinous heinous
scheme
so how do you feel speaking
how do you feel speaking in court
it actually felt very powerful to
finally have a chance to speak and and
you know have my voice on the record uh
and say the things that i wanted to say
about how her crimes had impacted the
people impacted myself and the people
that that i know and care about
honey how did you feel listening to her
in court uh just i'll just say one more
thing that yeah her her statement felt
like a very hollow apology to me she did
not take responsibility for the crimes
that she committed and it felt like once
more her trying to do something to
benefit her
and not at all about the harm that she
had caused